El gélido y solitario Ártico, el polo norte.
Este es uno de esos sitios de los que no solemos
oír hablar muy a menudo, salvo quizás cuando
de tiempo en tiempo salta alguna que otra
noticia sobre el derretimiento del hielo como
consecuencia del aumento de la temperatura
global.
Y ojo, porque más allá de los debates y
temas de corte ambiental o climático que
últimamente tanto inunda la actualidad política
y social, lo cierto es que la pérdida de
masa de hielo en el Ártico puede traer consigo
importantes consecuencias geopolíticas y
económicas.
Consecuencias, ojo, mucho más grandes de
lo que muchos podríais llegar a imaginar.
Es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado en VisualPolitik
en diferentes ocasiones.
Fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico.
En él podemos ver cómo ha evolucionado la
extensión de hielo en el Ártico durante
la última década y media.
En este caso creo que la imagen habla por
sí sola.
Queridos amigos, amigas, el Ártico se esta
calentando cuantro veces más rápido que
el resto del planeta.
Y eso tiene consecuencias.
Desde el punto de vista ambiental esto podría
provocar un gran cambio en la estabilidad
bioclimática.
Al tiempo que desde el punto de vista económico
y político este enorme cambio podría provocar
un montón de retos y oportunidades.
(Se prevé que la temporada libre de hielo
marino en el Ártico se extienda hasta el
otoño - European Geoscience Union)
(En 2022 el pico invernal del hielo marino
del Ártico ha sido el décimo más bajo registrado
- CarbonBrief
El hielo marino del Ártico alcanzó su máxima
extensión del año, con 14,88 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados (km2) el 25 de febrero.
Es el décimo pico invernal más pequeño
en el registro satelital de 44 años.)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué esto resulta algo tan
trascendente?
Puede provocar este cambio que las frías
e inhospitas aguas del Ártico se conviertan
en una de las regiones más importantes desde
el punto de vista geopolítico en apenas unos
pocos años.
Siendo más directo: ¿Puede el Ártico llegar
a convertirse en una nueva arteria para el
comercio mundial?
(Como podéis ver en este mapa, el deshielo
del Ártico abre la oportunidad de emplear
durante todo el año nuevas rutas comerciales
para el transporte marítimo de mercancías.
Nuevas rutas que acortarían a menos de la
mitad algunas de los trayectos marítimos
más importantes que hoy existen entre Europa
y Asia a lo largo del otoño y el invierno.
En la actualidad, estas rutas cada vez se
utilizan más a lo largo del año pero en
el fondo siguen siendo estacionales ya que
en invierno la superficie congelada del Ártico
se multiplica, cerrando con ello estas autopistas
del mar.
Sin embargo, esto es algo que está cambiando
poco a poco, lo que puede conllevar una transformación
total de los patrones logísticos de la economía
mundial y grandes oportunidades para las potencias
árticas.)
Y no solo eso, cómo ya os hemos contado en
alguna que otra ocasión, el Ártico también
está lleno de recursos naturales.
Valiosos recursos que hasta ahora no se han
podido explotar de forma rentable debido a
sus duras condiciones, al hielo y al frío.
Pero para que os hagais una idea del enorme
tesoro que puede haber bajo estas aguas, sabed
que el Servicio Geológico de Estados Unidos
estima que cerca dek 22% de todo el gas y
todo el petróleo del planeta tierra se encuentra
precisamente en esta región del mundo.
Y hablamos de petróleo y gas, pero podríamos
decir practicamente lo mismo de muchos minerales.
En otras palabras, todo un caramelito para
los miembros del selecto clúb del ártico:
Estados Unidos, Canadá, Islandia, Groenlandia
Noruega y, por supuesto, Rusia.
Y ojo que el país que hasta ahora ha llevado
la delantera para tomar el control no ha sido
otro que……
Rusia.
Durante los últimos años los esfuerzos de
Moscú por incrementar su control en la zona
han sido tan grandes que hoy por hoy casi
podríamos decir que es la potencia hegemónica
en estos lares.
[Aunque hasta ahora tampoco es que haya tenido
mucha competencia, la verdad.]
Pero, ¿Qué espera obtener Rusia por conseguir
controlar esta región y por qué decimos
que hoy por hoy lleva ventaja?
¿Hasta qué punto la guerra de Ucrania puede
cambiar los plaes de Moscú?
¿Qué planes tienen los países occidentales?
Pues bien, en este vídeo responderemos a
todas estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
(EL ‘PINGÜINO’ DE LOS HUEVOS DE ORO)
Lo sabemos absoutamente todos: Rusia es el
país más grande del mundo.
Una condición que le permite contar con más
de 24.000km de costa a lo largo del Océano
Ártico y las aguas del círculo polar ártico.
Solo es superado por Canadá, que tiene ni
más ni menos que 162.000km de costa ártica.
Claro que eso se debe sobre todo a la enorme
cantidad de islas que integran el territorio
del país en la zona.
Sea como sea, lo cierto es que Rusia tiene
una ventaja mucho más importante, y es que
a través de sus aguas pasa precisamente la
que está llamada a ser la ruta martítima
más importante en el futuro: la conocida
como ruta del mar del norte.
Una ruta que actualmente es utilizada durante
algunos meses en el verano, pero que en un
futuro no muy lejano podría ser navegable
durante todo el año.
(Durante el invierno de finales del 21 y principios
del 22, cruzaron por esta ruta 86 tránsitos
de barcos mercantes, una cantidad ínifima
en relación al tráfico que une Europa con
Asia, pero que supone el doble de actividad
que en 2019 y 43 veces más que en el año
2007.
Por el momento, estas operaciones suelen involucrar
a un rompehielos que avanza por delante del
buque mercante.
Y un dato importante, dos terceras partes
de los buques que transitaron por estas aguas
fueron enormes gaseros que transportaban gas
natural licuado, y también algunos petroléros.
Y esto ya desvela algo muy pero que muy importante:
la ruta podría ser clave para el transporte
energético entre Rusia y los consumidores
asiáticos, reduciendo con ello, además,
los costes de exportación a medio y largo
plazo.
Algo fundamental teniendo en cuenta que la
guerra de Ucrania está poco a poco desconectando
a Rusia de sus clientes occidentales.)
Y a ello, por supuesto, tenemos que sumarle
las importantísimas reservas de gas y petróleo
que puede haber en la zona.
Y de momento más del 80% de los yacimientos
de petróleo y gas natural en producción
son rusos.
De hecho la región es tan importante para
la economía rusa que lo que aquí se produce:
combustibles, minerales, capturas pesqueras…
Supone entorno al 20% de todas las exportaciones
del país
Y eso solo el principio.
El deshielo le permitiría a Rusia multiplicar
la explotación de recursos naturales y, sobre
todo, controlar, la ruta marítima más prometodora
entre Europa y Asia.
Lógicamente y tal y como os podéis imaginar
esto es algo que no le hace ni pizca de gracia
a las potencias occidentales.
Y es justo aquí donde junto a la carrera
económica nos encontramos con la carrera
militar.
Atentos.
(EL TELÓN DE HIELO)
Pensadlo un momento: Si vosotros controláseis
una parte tan destacada de una región tan
sumamente importante para el futuro de la
economía mundial y que además está en disputa
con otras partes, estoy convencido de que
apostariais por dedicar un montón de recursos
y esfuerzos para blindar hasta los dientes
vuestra presencia.
¿Me equivoco?
Seguro que no.
Pues, precisamente a esa misma conclusión
llegó el líder ruso Vladimir Putin practicamente
desde que se hizo con las riedas del Kremlin.
(En 2007 el gobierno ruso volvió a situar
al Ártico como una prioridad nacional y se
puso manos a la obra.
Tras una década y media, el ejército ruso
es hoy por hoy la fuerza que más presencia
tiene en todo el círculo polar ártico.
Desde que Putin llegó al poder, Rusia ha
reabierto 50 antiguos puestos militares soviéticos
que estaban clausurados, y ha remodelado 13
bases aéreas, 10 estaciones de radar, 20
puestos fronterizos y 10 estaciones de rescate
para emergencias.
Además también han incorporado unidades
de las Spetsnaz, las fuerzas especiales rusas,
en una de las Brigadas Árticas.)
La estrategia rusa ha dividido su despliegue
en dos flancos, el oriental y el occidental,
y cada una de estas mitades tiene equipamientos
desplegados y objetivos distintos.
Por ejemplo, el flanco oriental y a pesar
de ser el más próximo a las costas de Alaska
es el menos militarizado.
Salvo una base en la isla de Wrangel
no tiene despliegues militares importantes
en el extremo oriental del Ártico.
En esta zona Rusia se limita a controlar el
paso de buques y el tráfico aéreo a traves
de radares especiales para condiciones árticas,
los Sopka-2.
Sin embargo, a medida que avanzamos hacia
el oeste, la presencia militar rusa se multiplica.
De hecho, allí el Kremlin tiene desplegados
algunos de sus equipos más sofisticados para
defender dominios aéreos y marítimos en
diversas islas y bases por todo el extremo
norte de la Rusia continental.
[O al menos eso se supone, pues bueno, ya
es dificil fiarse de la capacidad real de
Rusia neta de corrupción e informes exagerados.]
Sea como sea, lo que sabemos es que en la
en la isla de Kotelny y en Novaya Zemlya,
Rusia cuenta con un importante blindaje de
defensas antibuque y antiaéreas, como los
sistemas antibuque Bastion-P y el sistema
de misiles antiaéreos Pantsir-S1, que es
uno de los equipos más modernos de Rusia.
(En esta zona, además, el Kremlin lleva desde
2019 desplegando los modernos radares Resonance-N,
que se cree que ya están operativos en tres
bases árticas y que permiten mejorar con
creces la operatividad militar y la precisión
de los sistemas antiaéreos y antibuque.
En Novaya Zemlya, de hecho, Rusia ha desplegado
recientemente sus baterías antiaéreas más
avanzadas, la joya de la corona rusa, las
S-400.
Y, por supuesto, las S-300, sus predecesoras,
también están desplegadas en varias posiciones
más a lo largo de toda esta costa)
Esto queridos amigos y amigas, es lo que la
comunidad internacional conoce como el nuevo
telón de hielo.
Digamos que durante los últimos años Rusia
ha trabajado duro para conseguir un objetivo:
tener la capacidad efectiva para desbordar
cualquier operación de la OTAN o Estados
Unidos en el Ártico, y sobre todo, tener
un control pleno sobre este terriotiro.
Pensad que el deshielo, además de brindarle
a Moscú la posibilidad explotar enormes recursos
naturales y controlar una vía comercial fundamental,
la ruta del mar del norte también le daría
al país una salida plena al mar, contrarrestando
con ello el “encierro” con que la OTAN
puede castigar a Rusia en el Mar Báltico.
Y precisamente por ello es en el flanco occidenta
dónde Rusia ha desarrollado con mucha diferencia
sus mayores esfuerzos militares.
De hecho, su Flota del Norte está estacionada
en Severomorsk, en la península de Kola,
a un paso de Finlandia.
Es el contingente más importante de la zona
y no solo cuenta con recursos navales, también
con equipos terrestes y aéreos, como por
ejemplo Mig-31.
Con este enclave, Moscu quiere reproducir
algo similar a la situación del corredor
de Suwałki [PRON: Suvawki] y los países
bálticos, es decir, llegado el caso poder
frenar el tránsito por el ártico de fuerzas
hostiles.
Y desde luego si os fijais en los mensajes
de Moscú veréis que el Ártico está cada
vez más presente:
(Rusia alerta a la OTAN de enfrentamientos
en el Ártico; Dice que el acceso de Suecia
y Finlandia al bloque militar liderado por
EE.UU. empeorará la situación - The Eurasian
Times)
​​(“No me extrañaría que Putin ahora
vea el Ártico como otra vía para el conflicto,
y una que le permitirá flexionar sus músculos.”
- Daniel Silverberg, director gerente de Capstone,
consultora de estrategia política de Washington
D.C.)
Por ahora, la presencia occidental en esta
zona es bastante reducida.
El Tio Sam apenas cuenta con una base militar
en Groenladia, la base de Thule y su presencia
en Alaska, una presencia que ahora está intentando
reforzar a toda velocidad:
(El Ejército de los Estados Unidos en Alaska
está haciendo una gran transformación para
convertirse en la Fuerza Ártica del Ejército.
Highnorthnews)
(El Ejército reactiva la 11a División Aerotransportada
en Alaska.
National Defense)
("Esperamos que (los miembros de la 11a Divisón),
sean maestros de su oficio en la guerra del
Ártico, luchando en condiciones de frío
extremo, en terrenos montañosos y de gran
altitud, y esperamos que desarrollen formas
innovadoras de operar en este entorno".
General James C.
McConville, Jefe del Estado Mayor del Ejército.)
Con todo, muchos analistas apuntan a que la
mejor baza para Estados Unidos es suministrar
enormes cantidades de armamento militar moderno
al resto de sus socios árticos.
Es decir, inundar de armamento defensivo las
costas árticas occidentales.
En otras palabras, que la guerra de Ucrania
está teniendo una traducción inmediata también
en el área que Rusia consideraba como toda
una prioridad.
La invasión de Ucrania puede no solo terminar
impulsando la militarizarión de toda esta
región, socavando con ello el liderazgo ruso,
sino que también puede suponer que la Ruta
del Mar del Norte no llegué a convertirse
en la autopista marítinma entre Asia y Europa
tan importante que estaba llamada a ser.
Así que sí, el sinsentido de la Guerra de
Ucrania puede hacer que Rusia termine pagando
un precio muy alto incluso en el ártico.
[Un desastre total.
Es lo que tiene lanzarte a una ola de aniquilación
y destrucción sin ningún sentido.
Con mucha diferencia la invasión de Ucrania
ha sido la peor jugada llevada a cabo por
Putin.]
De momento la creciente tensión entre Rusia
y Occidente ya se ha cobrado su primera víctima:
la investigación científica.
Un trabajo que hasta ahora se había llevado
a cabo de una forma relativamente abierta.
Pero eso se ha terminado.
(Científicos rusos y occidentales ya no colaboran
en el Ártico - The Economist)
También el llamado Consejo Ártico, un foro
para supervisar, conservar y prevenir desastres
en esta región del mundo ha sido suspendido.
Estas son las primeras consecuencias pero
podéis creerme cuando os digo que no serán
las últimas.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti ¿Crees
que el Ártico se convertirá en el próximo
escenario de confrontación con Rusia?
¿Conseguirá el comercio mundial esquivar
las dificultades geopolíticas para utilizar
las rutas marítimas árticas?
Déjanos tus opiniones aquí abajo, en los
comentarios.
Y, si te ha gustado este vídeo, no olvides
darle like y suscribirte al canal si es que
aún no lo has hecho.
Y muy importante, recuerda que ahora puedes
colaborar con VisualPolitik para que podamos
seguir haciendo más y mejores análisis apoyándonos
a través de nuestro Patreon.
Tenéis el enlace aquí abajo, en la descripción.
Como siempre, gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.